Film Courage: Jim, I know you joke about food,
you’ve written about food.
Do you ever think about the backstory of what
your character you are about to play eats?
Jim Gaffigan, Actor, Comic, Author: …That’s
a really interesting question.
I suppose I haven’t.
I do think…when we were shooting CHAPPAQUIDDICK
there was an amount of…these scenarios where
there is drinking, but I think that’s not
food.
But like there is this approach to drinking
and consumption of alcohol that has shifted
so much with every decade (at least in my
lifetime).
So this was kind of my Dad’s era where people
would drink just enormous amounts and they
would day drink and drink at night (it was
pretty amazing).
Film Courage: Did you ever consider what your
character might eat?
I know that drinking was a lot of what was
going on especially on those few days that
the film takes place?
Jim Gaffigan: I think I…what they would
eat?
Yeah, I don’t know.
That’s interesting.
I think it’s more the priority of eating.
Whereas, I think for me what I would eat and
the type of food I would eat is probably more
important than what it was back then.
It’s like you look back what we were having
at barbecues as a kid versus versus what we’re
having at barbecues now.
It’s kind of gotten fancier.
Film Courage: Fondues and things like that.
Jim Gaffigan: Yeah.
Film Courage: Why do you think comedians make
such great actors?
Jim Gaffigan: Well…I mean that’s flattering.
I would say that comedians, it’s really
necessary to know yourself, that that’s
part of the journey and that’s part of the
conversation you have with the audience and
how they respond to things, particularly autobiographical
things.
So you become very aware of who you are and
how you come across.
But I don’t know?
I think of acting and stand-up as very different
disciplines but I also love acting because
in some ways it’s the opposite from stand-up.
Whereas stand-up I’m writer, director, producer
and ever beat and moment of the show is controlled
and influenced by me.
I love the opportunity to be this spoke in
this larger, just even a moment in a scene
serving a narrative of a story is really exciting
and also it’s fun to kind of hide in a different
character and have a different point of view.
And I think in my stand up I kind of engage
different points of views.
But in acting it’s really fun to kind fo
climb behind a different point of view and
see how they would adjust.
Of course, it’s still you.
But like playing Paul Markham, you know, he’s
a lawyer.
I think that influenced how he viewed everything.
It was also somebody who really liked Ted
[Kennedy].
So I think those elements really had an influence.
Whereas in stand-up there is a greater likelihood
of taking the irreverent point of view.
Film Courage: Have we learned anything from
Chappaquiddick all of these years later?
Or it’s just a moment in time, no one really
knows what happened?
Jim Gaffigan: There’s so much information
out there.
And some of it, the information I know know
how definite it is.
I think it’s how our viewpoint on Chappaquiddick
is shifting, just particularly in this day
in age that we live in so…I mean look our
viewpoint on inebriated driving has shifted
dramatically in our lifetime.
I remember being a kid and hearing about inebriated
driving and being like “Try not to do it!”
And now, no one would do it.
And so, obviously this tragedy, no one should
ever do this.
But like the alcohol or the philandering part,
our judgments on that have changed dramatically.
Film Courage: Excellent!
Thank you.
Jim Gaffigan: Thank you.
Appreciate it.